can you hear us that's the first
question can you hear us
can you hear us we should probably go to
the chat we should make sure the people
are responding we have plenty whether
you're Raj is here you hear us
how's it going Carter Lovejoy we will
get to your question don't you fret
mm-hmm got em case songbird in here you
guys can hear us Hawaii's asked RTM
midnight will starfish don't go on cam
dinner Chronicle Anakin Skywalker Josh
run cheater TV what's up buddy Chronicle
record deal starfish Kane already funny
me me am buddy huh huh
John Irish Ethan wait Oh mark fold we
can hear you good Thank You Niraj that's
who I wanted to know but I wanted to
make sure exactly just you specifically
well no worry we've been obeying the
social distancing rules for the most
part I'd say I say we've been pretty
good on it yeah John's the only one who
comes into this home or else he just
comes home that's how it's been how's
everything been going for you guys on
your end so many homes in my life hungry
that's what's up where are you guys all
from what are you guys gonna do with the
Vette empty trailer well we're gonna
kill cosmic Wonder yeah that's for sure
yeah this is all his no there's no way
around it blame him for the report
reading the reports you're seen are your
first live stream Oh welcome we got
someone here from Australia I love
Totino's yeah just trying to check how
many people are in this stream right now
and also why is John John's always here
thanks Andrew I'm going to be speaking
directly to you for the rest of the ride
just to make you happy Oh Rach I do
thank you thank you so much record deal
all right guys so for if you guys are
not able to read what's on the screen
right now it's a day's topic I want to
kind of shift gears a little bit here
make it something really simple I was
thinking we could just talk about movies
and shows that make us feel good these
could be your own person
all picks they don't have I was gonna
say feel-good movies or feel-good shows
but honestly it's like some people might
have some weird pics things that might
be a little bit unusual and so I thought
it'd be fun to mix it up with things
like that and I'll kick it off and yeah
we'll be covering some super chats in
between but also be covering your guys's
comments as we keep going yeah now that
there's like a hundred people that are
in here at the moment I wanted to
quickly say if my energy dips in and out
it's kind of a rough day yesterday
something sudden sort of happened and I
don't want to spend too much time on
this because I want to just use today to
get my mind off of things since honestly
these live streams have been undoubtedly
the most fun we've been having on
YouTube over the last few weeks it's
just been fun actually really
interacting with you guys but yesterday
if you guys might have seen maybe follow
me on Instagram or if you follow or
you've seen him in videos ever
we had a squirrel that my girlfriend
saved a month ago a little over a month
ago fell off of a tree squirrels whole
family unfortunately died but he
survived named him Ricky and we tried
finding the right people that dropped
him off too but would the coronavirus
situation happening oh we're getting the
camera back don't you worry with the
coronavirus situation happening there
are people that just couldn't take him
there are people gonna drop him off to
the right groups and then some and we've
my my cousin's actually a vet and we
know people who have squirrels or like
well one would just keep him then and
then unfortunately yesterday it was so
sudden
Ricky actually passed away while at the
bet we noticed some neurological issues
were happening it was all just happening
at once and apparently the brain damage
from the fall of when we first picked
him up it we didn't realize that there
was like this just prolonged effect that
it was eventually gonna catch up to him
and would drop him off the vet they had
to put him under anesthesia and it was
really heartbreaking
I've we've been incredibly emotional
my girlfriend Olivia and I and then even
this morning has been very emotional
starting to just feel better so I just
want to say kiss my energy I know
normally on these live streams I'm
pretty freaking out there and really
ecstatic but I wanted to take a little
bit of a comma approach and I wanted to
get suggestions from you guys of what
you think is a great feel-good movie
and/or show and yeah I just wanted to
say that because I didn't want anything
to and also and Niraj I appreciate I
just see the super chat and Carter thank
you I appreciate both super chatting
about that I also was but I was
literally just about to go into this hey
if anyone super chats based off of like
Ricky at all I mean I appreciate you
guys doing that at the same really do at
the same time I don't want any like any
like sympathetic or pity super chats
come in your condolences are always
appreciated and whatnot you know just
leave it in the chat but please don't
want to be like you know getting super
chats based off of that but I just
wanted to clarify that and I wanted to
be I wanted to be transparent but I also
wanted to use this live stream to start
getting some dopamine hits in oh my god
these live streams usually make me feel
really great they have I feel pretty
good being here it's not like I'm going
to just get over the loss of an animal
that really felt like part of the family
right away but I feel great when I do
these live streams are always so
euphoric so yeah I mean it's like we've
been doing these weekly and I just
wanted to mention that really quick and
I'm sure my energy will pick up as we
keep going but just want to state that
up front so thank you guys and thank you
to everyone who's saying r.i.p ricky and
stuff like that i just wanted to mention
that but now it's but we can move on i
wanted to kick it off on my favorite
with my feel-good movie during
quarantine has been and we'll go through
the comets and such and thank you for
everyone who's been super checking so
far don't worry we'll get there everyone
my favorite feel-good movie so far
during this quarantine time is actually
the Austin Powers trilogy I randomly put
on the first one international man of
mystery because olivia has never seen it
and I was surprised about how funny it
still is you know a little feeling
controversial but and honestly and I saw
Austin Powers Goldmember has the lowest
rated audience score but I actually felt
that was the best one that was my fate
personal favorite one that one felt like
the most like a real movie to me and I
love Goldmember so I would say that the
best feel-good movie for me for in terms
of a comedy I got several actually but I
want to keep that off with saying Austin
Powers John you got one in the meantime
in centipede alright I wanna go to Joe
cancer Serbian film that's like a deep
cut one one thing I want to shout out
right at the top which is a newer not
discovery for me but something I've seen
a lot more of in these past handful of
weeks it's not like necessarily my
absolute favorite but if you want to
feel good and you want to escape a
little bit and you want to indulge in
light-hearted wonderfully imaginative
animation go watch some episodes of
Shaun the Sheep or watch the Shaun the
Sheep new New York all because those are
so they're they're wholesome but they're
also clever they're fun and I think all
ages will find something to cackle at
with that show so that's good it highly
recommend if you want to feel nice oh
good to know we ran some like Ace
Ventura movies in here someone saying
Schindler's List scar to Lovejoy the
lego movie good one I missed Mike Myers
two guys thor ragnarok
i think out of all the MCU movies I
would say that or guardians one of the
best feel-good movies for sure Parent
Trap not bad now I took too long with uh
they a sergeant cheesecake first time
tuning in master octagon South Carolina
thank you for tuning in for your first
time we're gonna hop alternate between
here in the Super chats and then okay
apparently I took too long explaining a
certain situation and now I I'm not able
to flash Carter Lovejoy super chat on
screen but here it is the first one from
Carter Lovejoy a frequent subscriber who
is here in our lives thank you for being
so consistent by the way dude a movie
that always puts me in a good mood and
is also my favorite film of all time
Ferris Bueller's Day Off that film
helped me through a lot of tough times
when I was in high school well I can
respect that
well you know what's funny about that
movie is I keep I'm constantly hearing
problematic things about that are you
not you know you're like problematic
things about that movie I'm hearing I
mean in would to be fair it is one of
those woke culture arguments and I'm the
last guy to try to act like I'm anti ok
absolute culture not that guy
I do see however that is one of those
movies that where people are able to go
who's a problematic things about that
first move is kind of addictive Cameron
Ferris Bueller is kind of like me and
John would be camera so I would describe
Ferris Bueller's Day Off that's where
the problematic issues lie with I see
that's the thing is I kind of associate
that with you know like hot take
opinions but I didn't know that there
have been like a cultural reexamine
Ferris Bueller's Day I don't know if I'm
misinterpreting that but ya know I can
see it I mean I could I could definitely
imagine it's been a hot that's a movie I
should go watch again because it's been
since I was like a young teenager
probably last time I saw it oh he said
imagine which made me think that of why
hard a Dewey Cox story most underrated
comedy ever I would say that's a great
feel that movie always up lifts my
spirits yeah oh you know what else I
love you man that is such a wonderfully
heart war especially you know if you got
a good bro that you love yeah yeah I
don't think of you I don't think of you
either
I don't know but seriously I always
remember when we used to go to test
screenings constantly that was one of my
favorite ones when we went back at
Paramount they gave us pirouettes and
they only cut one scene down from the
film that even mother would the
questionnaires that's how much of a good
time everybody had and I'm I always look
back on that as one of my favorite like
movie screening experiences any what
people are saying Adam Sandler or Jim
Carrey exact never be saying these
livestreams are my feel-good show out so
sweetie you daddy
grand Budapest hotel ice that is the Wes
Anderson feel-good movie I would say
yeah yeah especially it's it's got the
best balance I
think of that fairytale nough Swift the
intrigue in the rise just something so
warm at the core of it that 70 show from
Carrie that's a great call alright call
rec I'm Rex a good one who okay
oh we got another super chat here for
raka do hey buddy look at the Rocket
Raccoon friend over here How to Train
Your Dragon just watch all three with
the group on discord for our movie
nights these those are my favorite
feel-good movies stay safe G and J thank
you so much for actually I appreciate
the super chat the How to Train Your
Dragon films we were actually on doing a
podcast or patreon recently and we were
talking about our favorite animated
movies and how dream work movies tend to
dip yeah like they usually just keep
going let's keep making a sequel so they
stop making money but How to Train Your
Dragon is a solid trilogy that is a damn
feel-good movie super under a fair like
the third one did not get enough money
that's a movie to wear that's a special
trilogy to me because I don't
necessarily love one specific movie but
I think the trilogy as a complete unit
is terrific movie and really well-done
trilogy Toy Story movies yes especially
the third one that ending so feel good
oh god I love that trash compactor Toy
Story 4 so feel good
somebody's just said American Werewolf
that's a good call oh we caught up with
the super Chauncey Trey Stallings love
that profile pic dude what's up guys
love your channel well I love your
profile pic you look happy approachable
and like somebody is literally zooming
the camera at you while they took this
fun I every time I hear the name Trey I
think of like some high school tall
blond douchebags quarterback yeah great
Trey trip and trends or that guy in my
skew undoubtedly exactly you undoubtedly
look like the nicest Trey I have ever
seen so keep that going that's a mantle
you thank you for being you Trey
appreciate that very much
shouts out cuz Gabriel Lopez apparently
loves your girlfriends oh thank you to
be 11 the che I Got News for you I love
my girlfriend - she's incredible
really watching these livestream watched
someone's the livestream ever in my life
I know I've never been something ever
live streams are great because they're
like podcasts without the replay factor
I always go to a person's live stream if
I'm hearing about like ooh some [ __ ]
went down they're having a meltdown like
when John that's a I'm going to but not
to I'm just gonna say not to to bring up
awesome old drama when John Campea went
off on Jack I and oh I was like I'm
gonna find this part of the larger
because I always love watching the
segues into yeah I'm watching like the
lead-up into it watching so that was
kind of opened the door into ire that
feels like it's so long ago too and it
was really wasn't it's like The Simpsons
Movie
great call for a feel-good movie that is
certainly a feel-good movie you know who
that movie made feel good Gary Oldman
and his children down the row from us
when we saw the simpsons movie Gary
Oldman
who was definitely filming one of the
Batman films at the time oh yes sure if
we just look at whatever year the
Simpsons came out if that was pre Dark
Knight or not but he had the hair the
glasses the know yeah that was one of
those things where because I'm right
we're right here and he's in our row
Gary Oldman and just look over same
sense of humor like Gary Oldman like
screw humor yeah and classic adult
animation you did not see me which
pop-tarts commercial red warrior you'd
be a surprised how many toaster strudels
commercials jon is actually how many
commercials I didn't know I was in Oh
Britney Lang you're always hearing
always changing your profile pic to keep
that up hey guys how's it going first
and foremost so sorry for your loss of
pet squirrel so sad
thank you bro I can't help it
I'm not laughing and I appreciate that I
really do it seriously you don't need a
like no needs contribute super Jets to
Ricky's passing I appreciate that but
you know don't want to like feel like
we're getting super shots off of that
but I appreciate that and the thing that
made me laugh is just imagine Donald
Trump saying that the best squirrel so
sad
don't ever get into me like I can't take
anything as sympathetic from you man if
he's give me a eulogy it's the worst
very sad
everybody is the most sad satisfy when
Trump jr. died yeah baby you can come in
oh I love how are you you got love in
the chat somebody thinks you're the best
part of the chance people have been
saying you for the best yeah you want to
pop your head in really fast
you don't look awful you look you look
this is the best kind of live stream
when you're talking to someone who's not
in frame by the way for all you know
nobody's even there this is a real
hangout live show I just want you guys
to know that don't worry
yeah I fed the cow entertaining you and
the meantime that's right woo feel-good
movies supernatural as a feel-good show
at the point that we're at in the show
I'm like looking over here at all sudden
I come back like I'm taking over
we just started season five things are
feeling pretty heavy but I imagine that
if we were caught up that would be a
perfect feel-good show we got a gray
pick here Shaun of the Dead yes that is
a surprising you know what yeah I would
say that is one of the best feel-good my
personal thanks I'm I remember feeling
elated when that movie was done that's
who Edgar Wright movie that's done that
for me you might say Hot Fuzz for you
for me Hot Fuzz Shaun of the Dead was a
film that
I remember being so surprised by I watch
I keep saying Papa yeah that's a great
pic who said that one eyed on racks
thank you buddy
I think I would agree with you on Shawn
specifically because Shawn is not the
dead part no especially because
everybody is just like a regular person
character they're not cops they're not
you know like rehab folks like it is the
movie that comes together we're by the
in your line
yeah maybe life's gonna be all right
yeah yeah and especially with the stuff
tab like I think they have a lot of
clever ways of making you feel well it's
the best friend thing it's romantic and
it is a romantic storyline part to it
that's good cool I love that one great
call oh my god both DC Marvel and Star
Wars and the dark universe have said
love your videos you guys watch these
are the best kind of super chats one one
my short answer is now have you guys
watched miracle in cell number seven
it's a great emotional feel-good movie I
liked the Turkish version on Netflix no
I have not seen miracle in cell numbers
honestly when you say miracle in cell
number seven Turkish I imagine the most
hard-hitting drama of all time it's
really really bleak and grueling but the
miracle is that after three and a half
hours the guy does get out of prison
into nothing of a life what was the what
was that that that the Willem Dafoe any
prison movie i watch of a person in
prison that always answered them being
like ridiculously skinny this actually
was like a powa film which which makes
sense
[ __ ] accurate but that's what I
imagined a miracle in cell number seven
but now I will have to check it out
definitely appreciate the contribution
from Canada googling it now so that I
think everyone's saying RIPD a little
Ricky he seriously was the best
seriously we don't think you know where
the venom 2 trailer is the ROG thank you
buddy I appreciate that
and Carter Lovejoy thanks so much thank
you you're very very kind of you
Gabriel Lopez I want venom 2 to be real
it is don't worry this is just a trick
it's not an April Fool's trick that
Sony's playing
what about show is John do you have a
show that always puts you in a good mood
I mean my obvious pick is friends
friends is my favorite show of all time
so I would say friends for sure
I wonder if there's like a drama that
weirdly I just feel so good but it's
weird like they're tight like better
call Saul does not make like it's not a
feel good show but whenever it's done
I'm always like this is such a good show
that I feel good for watching it yeah
Curb Your Enthusiasm I would say is
another fantastic feel good show
fantastic man that guy has just changed
so many words you know what the best way
is not not to keep plugging our honestly
like no please do maybe the episode we
watch today because it was heavier
honestly watching episodes of Doctor Who
really do make me feel very like bouncy
and happy afterwards you know even if
they are intense sweet we just watched
this episode of Doctor Who and when the
Rose character meets her it's in
Eccleston season where Rose meets her
father Father's Day and that I've
already been crying enough as it is yeah
that episode Wow mmm I'd say pull myself
back from being there gets a point where
you're watching just someone really I
just stop doing this myself because the
thing is like when I when I when I do
like cry at a movie especially I I'm
always fighting back the obnoxious
noises I know that are coming out of my
nose and mouth if you guys saw the
corona heroes what does it heroes United
United coronavirus video from my be
Raccoon we did a reaction to it and I
was holding back my tears but then in
the in the review part you can just see
like I had to point it out as like
people are gonna put the [ __ ] out you
see like and it's like feel-good tears
so it's on topic you can see like snot
booger on my beard my moustache is so
embarrassing that's how you know it's
gonna call it out before other people do
Jennifer Hudson cry get the nose going
yeah
Parent Trap that's a good one you know
what his name drop in Supernatural today
over a patreon pluged a feel-good show I
just had one on the tip of my tongue
it's not it's not the news the fan you
know Johnson that's a feel-good common
right there you guys are the best in our
aspiring budding filmmaker and
screenwriter best of luck on stern
writing buddy I gotta work on a script
tonight actually not on filmmaking
itself good no luck there yeah you know
what is a great feel-good show and you
know different than what we normally
talk about but if you want to be soothed
and titillated by art watch Heather like
the great british baking show or the
great pottery throwdown just watch one
of those shows where British people
competitively do art because they're so
supportive of each other the art is
great it makes you want to create and
there's like a tone that just the
American shows are all about you know
driving you insane and pounding your
pulse with like how bad people are but
you watch like a couple of people make
some pots for 45 minutes it's wonderful
I mean I will meet you on the opposite
spectrum and then we'll get your shoe
Thank You Marissa
Redell thank you so much lovely profile
pic you look absolutely gorgeous the
what was the my girlfriend I watched
nailed it is so fun
we love nailed it it's weird because
it's it's the same joke for four seasons
the same joke which is people try to
emulate this crazy this crazy and I saw
Roxy Strider and Maurin Opik they
brought it up on on their live stream
they if you haven't seen nailed it on
Netflix basically the three competitors
and their bait there's a baking
competition and I don't know how to bake
and I generally don't like baking shows
but the shows so funny they have these
three competitors that are trying to
basically emulate this crazy thing to
bake
and then you just watch them within a
like you just watched how these people
who suck at baking come out with this
like ridiculously looking creation where
every every every punchline the funniest
punchline it's the same one every time
is you guys [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I
truly adore about that show too is I I
don't know how they make it but I do
know that with a lot of competition
shows there are takes that are done over
there yeah that aren't confined to the
time they say they are and on nailed it
I feel like they literally do just give
people the amount of time they say they
do and watch as people struggle with
that yeah it's like it's brilliant it
feels like it keeps it real mo Marissa
thank you so much for the super chat my
dear psych is definitely my feel-good TV
show right now so excited for the second
movie I'm kind of confused by your
comment
this is psycho show or a movie when you
said second movie do you mean second
season is that we were saying and I've
heard a lot of great things about psych
you haven't seen psych
but I've heard a lot of great things
about it no and it's stuck around so I
every time somebody brings it up now I'm
more and more interested to check it out
but I yeah was a show on USA and I guess
now they got their second movie going so
they are living the dream so many shows
so there was a show then there was a
movie now there's a second movie oh wow
must be feel-good what a know every time
I caught a at least a promo it did look
like it had a certain quirky vibe that
could be you know fun to get into we got
Cedric here saying Cretu every time he
watches it it wants to hit the gym
afterwards yeah every rock even look at
Rocky movies make me do that yeah we
just watch it'll work out if you want to
work out it's the way it goes and then
you need the credits roll and you're
like yeah I'm tired you know they may
come sire movies where people just work
out and that's it yeah and they sell
them on VHS you don't even have to go to
the theater called pumping iron pum and
iron
Linnea Quigley's scream queen workout up
fell behind on super jets again so sorry
about that
yeah we got a weird loading page I
wonder when the internet gets better
again
more people when you guys are actually
able to go outside when you aren't
honking of the internet when you're out
and not able to tune into our live
streams because you're outside know what
you guys need new they means we'll be
able to keep up with the supership you
need to ping your signals through other
servers by signing up for a VPN such as
blaze VPN who have been working with
recently so that you're not maxing out
the servers here in the United States we
should have called this theme today sell
out sell out in fact we're not even
sponsored by these people you should buy
this any okay so we got a super chat
here from booty Surfer 1981 oh what an
interesting name you got here alright so
booty surfer don't know if whoa this is
a weird comment I wish I could show it
on screen for you guys oh here well if
we can just detach the camera and point
it we could share our screen probably
experimental wire stream things in
advance let's see they don't show these
tips again all right now we want to go
over to share owner yeah whoa is that
yes it is this one right here love from
Wales a Welsh purse I don't know how to
do all shacks from Wales as a Welshman
just like to ask you sire say my name it
name of a town in Wales oh my god how do
we say that John give it a shot yoanne
Griffith
yeah and purple going Silla gaga is that
real or are you messing with me I know
in Wales you guys use the Welsh language
whatever it is uses letters in places
that I normally wouldn't but I was
you're in a point where I'll just
believe that that's a real place
remember that thank you so much by the
way footy surfer 1981 to Wales Remember
the Titans ah great call great call I
cannot hear that song I don't even know
the title
to it no no good without thinking of The
Lincoln Lawyer like I couldn't think of
that actual football movie who is
Matthew McConaughey Matthew Fox
I know stars the [ __ ] where was that
movie called longest Sunday I can't pull
it to mind at all filled have you guys
seen the Harley Queen animated series
not yet unfortunately sorry okay so
let's see here
Colson Cooley appaluse alright guys
we're gonna do let's let's get the okay
okay I'm at the quick share screen again
this is such this is such good quality
live streaming make this Johnny cameo
and Sen Network can't keep up with make
it fullscreen and then just share the
right hand screen alright John you click
away watch out people tell you guys
about the shower I took today look out
oh man was it sexy I bathe every day I
was in there for way too long
oh hey guys first live stream Oh cult
Cinco Oh John you did it yeah this is
great screen look we got right here hey
guys first live stream first super chat
thank you so much had a really tough day
today hey I can identify buddy really
can you guys always make me feel better
no question love your stuff well thank
you so much Coulson thank you for
sharing that means sometimes they say
giving make someone feel good so thank
you for sharing that dude and that's
what we whenever we do these live
streams the note that we always make and
they actually prove it live you might a
copy doing it which was I might have
caught her right at the tail end there
make people do it I should be putting my
hand on the mic right now make let's
make these people feel good let's just
go out there and just have them have a
good time and so yeah thank you but that
means a lot because sheep will feel fun
feels good tour that and is that Johnny
Depp from that's hunter s Thompson on
your thumb Mel hunter yeah I gotcha
ooh femme fatale John do your thing
share the right screen there we go
since we're bout hi oh look at the
options I'll just I'll take one for the
team and move over move over here really
disobeyed femme fatale thank you so much
supernatural for sure I just re-watched
all of your reactions so you're a
patreon page Thank You femme fatale was
getting my SPN tat what is your SPN
tattoo that's exciting it's supernatural
tat now I've heard of people getting
real rejects tattoos but Supernatural
have they really stablished themselves
enough alright Jared Padalecki and
Jensen Ackles might get cancelled one
day they might do something stupid yeah
they're from Texas okay you just never
know
yeah Jared might get arrested outside of
a restaurant he owns or something and
all my friends from Texas have all been
arrested so they're probably going to
get in trouble right a passage in Texas
I'm told it's kidding I'm just joking
they're pure human beings they could do
nothing wrong you know if they do
something wrong but thank you thank you
so much and thank you for watching our
supernatural reactions that means a lot
SPN tattoo I like would you wait until
the show was done just to make sure you
know what I would get if I got
supernatural tattoos I would do one on
my hand that says just watch and then on
my back between my shoulders I'm just
gonna get cast also just a just a
reminder announcement this holds from
last week if we can get 200 concurrent
eyeballs in this room or 175 if I happen
to be feeling generous I am going to
share with you all a surprise I have no
idea what the surprise isn't saying it
is I'm more like whoever's in here let's
just hang out with whoever's here that's
got something my rule of thumb mm-hmm
but one of these John wants to do the
livestream thing where you get to 200
people and you do something special
which is cool so share this livestream
but I'm more like whoever's here I'm
just talking with you guys if we're
coming to get down to only five people
I've got something in store
okay so then where do we got here
Indiana Jones series the whole series
even though even the fourth one of the
crystals alright as we can Melanie how
you doing Melanie it's great to see you
great to see you Melanie Jim Varney's
Ernest movies any of Jim Varney's Ernest
movies personal favors Ernest scared
straight that or the original Willy
Wonka guy remember Ernest oh man Ernest
what happened to you dude is he alive no
jim Varney passed yeah and why didn't
you tell me that before I just made an
ass out of myself I should tell me that
I should have told you that ten years
ago God we could edit it out of the
video with the feel like a stupid yeah I
know now you're an idiot every time you
watch Toy Story huh I love slinky dog
and his original voice actor in part
four okay so another great feel-good
movie and I saw it brought up here in
the chat anchorman another feel-good one
of my yeah or not absolutely favorite
one and to piggyback off Ernest wrong
time of year but Ernest saves Christmas
is definitely one that I come back to
each holiday season potato was life what
is that oh you know like when you put
two forks in a potato and you connect
them by a wire and you can turn them
into a light bulb whoo that's science I
never did a very good apparently lots of
kids do umm okay another feel-good show
for me hmm
would have to be I would actually say no
wait I want to I want to shout this one
out really fast i watch this randomly
the other night as a Netflix stand-up
special we started the Kristen I really
like Kristi Elia actually I think he's
one of the best comedians around we
started living I started his stand-up
special we're just gonna get into it at
the time I guess I just wasn't Christie
Elliot mood and she said try something
out let's just look for something that
is random some standard special as we
tend to find a good gem sometimes when
we do that and we came across a comedian
never seen her or heard of her before
called the specials called quarter life
crisis really recommend this Taylor
Tomlin I think is her name or Taylor
tellenson Tomlinson Taylor Tomlin no
I've heard this name
it is a hysterical stand-up she's only
25 years old really funny stuff though
really really really funny so if you
guys like watching Sando specials
especially the ones on Netflix really
recommend her that definitely feel good
actually watching Santa specials is like
the best way to feel good for me yeah is
my favorite way of doing any feel-good
thing in fact I've been champing at the
bit to catch that new Marc Maron that
was ok I was kind of dork
that's actually not gonna be the
escapism the cathartic conference
someone's asked if we watch good boys
haven't seen good boys no I haven't seen
that yet all right here's what we'll do
because of the share screen that we have
to do to keep up with the super chats
we'll lean to the left yes right that's
what we have to do yeah I mean we
basically we need to be like in center
we got to be kind of like centered the
way we did go there wait that doesn't
make sense you come here they're obvious
lightly behind use of the weaken
distance all right so we got uh who we
missed Brendan Behan V he's the guy last
week who said we should wear bandanas
and I'm sorry mine's been a little bit
clouded leave did not bring the bandanas
tonight oh thank you so much dude I'll
raid my bandana I mean John's got a bane
mask you wear of course knows a half as
being a terrible BAE of course I haven't
tried to do the voice in literally to
you problem with this mask even though
it does it does give your voice this
quality it's [ __ ] of John's alright
that's the bandana for today Britney
Lange thank you so much again oh you're
so sweet I can't wait to see your
profile pic do you have next week always
changing it up my feel-good movie of the
this the step-up saga I love dancing
movies or center stage
3d is both a a really enjoyable film and
B has terrific 3d wonder what my
favorite dance movie would be I would
say Saturday Night Fever is a great film
but my feel-good dance movie would be
the sequel directed and written by
sylvester stallone called stay alive
that is so bad is so awful and so like
unnecessarily high-stakes dramatic in
the finale that right there made me feel
[ __ ] good that I would say that's my
favorite dance movie so thanks for
sharing that Britney Lang may be
Strictly Ballroom oh yes good your call
there good call there mr. marshmallow oh
thank you mr. marshmallow Revenge of the
Nerds who otherwise from problematic the
fast owns not so problematic all
problematic yes I've seen the
Flintstones since I thought thought
thought in the theater well thank you
mr. Marsh well I have a question to
springboard off of yours then got John
and people in the chat if you were to
recast Fred and Barney who would you put
as modern-day actors Oscar Isaac and Ben
Foster yeah and then uh and any circus
he can mocap denote we've got up here
now before we catch up okay so we got
ricotta and this uh thank you so much
dear hey guys just got off work was a
super crazy day had three crazy
situations three serious situations
coming so I needed this live today Coco
is my feel-good movie it reminds me of
my great grandmother that's weird
because aren't you Russian yeah you're
like you're like Jesus or no way you can
identify any
yeah I don't get why you would
appropriate somebody else's culture and
pretend to be a part of it just to make
yourself feel special Coco was one of
those movies where I was really glad I
had 3d glasses on because I was a mess I
was a weeping willow like I could not
stop yeah that was like non-stop tears
beautiful and I and a heart mini thing
doing film that is undoubtedly the Pixar
movie it's probably it's still not my
favorite Pixar movie but it's the one I
cried the most good tears yeah good
tears yeah I can feel that for you I
mean us that I'm more likely to cry as
something that makes me overwhelm that
feels good and is very touching then I
mean sad stuff will make me cry but more
often than not its feel-good things that
make me cry
lately I found out move by love see I
cry the most during movies at like when
when a character puts their finger on
like a specific nuance that's like
really true but also hard to articulate
yeah it's a very specific thing so then
you get that feeling of like feeling why
am i crying this isn't even a sad
situation yeah you know it's another
feel-good movie for me and someone said
ghostbusters in the chat thank you for
saying that it's another great one but
another feel-good movie for me I would
say is the nice guys Ryan Gosling and
Russell Crowe just saw that again on TV
that's definitely a feel-good movie from
a horrific and I thought with that with
a shame black thing Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
I think is another great you see I
wanted to do this topic today because
someone put out on Twitter recently and
they tagged me in it I'd like a bunch of
Schmo down people over like what movies
you recommend and watched her in
quarantine and I don't remember
specifically who answered what I just
noticed a lot of people were answering
films that are like such good underrated
dramas which I think are fine to watch
during this time it's like you know I'm
like well what would I really want to
watch I don't do I really want to like
check out like Schindler's List at this
moment every Belle station do it
something like that but super bad that's
a great feel good movie Thank You Cedric
for pointing that
ooh you know what's another one in that
vein when I saw Horrible Bosses I was
having any bad day and it made my day
better Horrible Bosses is a really good
first movie that first one yeah what
would you say guys I want to expand this
question out as we're catching up with
the comments and stuff what would you
say is a feel-good movie that someone
might not identify as feel good but
really does make you feel good bad boys
3 no that could qualify John it's about
family all the fast and furious then I
would say Babu sri is weirdly like if JJ
Abrams rebooted it with the fast and
furious what's a few and I just do that
question out there and I'm trying to
come up with an answer now I've won that
where I would say is a weird
qualification for me as well I well I
watched this movie last night so it may
just be because of that but I maybe
there's a lot of drama and up and down
are you gonna say ParaNorman again I'm
gonna say oh brother where art thank God
there Norman is a feel-good movie amount
of times you drop this ParaNorman Hera
Norman is a lot of great things but feel
good is not necessarily at the top of
that list but I watched oh brother are
though again and that movie definitely
is not one of the most overt Coen
comedies but I feel like the way that
movie handles its drama mixed with it's
comedy where it ends up the height of
the characters and the bond that pulls
the three main dudes together I think
there is something feel-good at the
heart of that movie that you wouldn't
necessarily find in like a Fargo or
something like that you know I would
really say Avengers end game yeah yeah
someone might not call that a feel-good
movie especially because like the first
hours really dour it's an hour dour I
would say tower hour but man when you
get to that ending I mean is
heart-wrenching as some of that is it's
such a rewarding experience I would say
end game that's a movie that's not
necessarily like feel good but that
involves people putting their all into
something and succeeding that's that's a
movie of people running to feel good
for five years
Ian's tutela thank you so much dude Ian
Sotelo from our patreon yes
keeping in the sell-out project yeah
sorry this is random but can you guys do
a music video reaction to Luis Capaldi
someone you love please you guys are
awesome keep it well we do music video
reactions we got our patreon job that's
the next one going I write it down look
at that I'm taking a write it down I
mean we can make this fat there you go
there you go
alright guys gonna go through comments
here expect it let's quickly read off
someone's Shane Dawson is the best Sam
is saying hmm good call somebody
Warren does not need to get slapped hey
guys you know what some people thought
that video we did with Warren where were
you cussing at him was genuine like we
were really mad I'm like no we were I
don't think the video Livius you ships
to come in and be like good [ __ ] guy
didn't know that we were doing I was
like okay I'm gonna call you I'm gonna
say you just gotta say [ __ ] how
we actually that video came together as
we called up Warren and we were like
listen we're really mad about this
okay like why would you agree to be in
it if it was genuine
marriage story my favorite just in just
a Kessler's a marriage story I don't
know if I can meet you there dude
the life of brian that is a great not
quite feel good but feel good movie
especially for the always look on the
bright side of life song the caps
everything off so lassic zachary sane an
underrated comedies role models i would
say that i feel like i mean my the
number one underrated comedy i would say
is is walk hard i think that is a
beautifully crafted film and it does not
get enough praise I do like role models
and and role models made me think of the
wrong movie I thought of drillbit Taylor
and then I thought of made Hartley back
people are saying the Goldbergs in here
the naked someone here really loves spy
spoof comedy The Naked Gun and a half
one and two are a great Johnny English
yes Johnny English
first scary movie police academy series
you know what is a oh my god I just
thought have a really great site you
know and I think of a like underrated
film one that definitely did not perform
well at the box office but I but really
moved me and I thought was hilarious
absolutely hilarious and I really wish
more people saw it I I really didn't
have interests to catch in the theaters
and then I have the HBO now app and I've
randomly put it on just as something no
there's none of those things you know
when you're like I got a dinner but I
gotta do [ __ ] afterwards so I'm gonna
put on like something for like a half
hour and I'm watching the whole thing
Seth Rogen and Charlize Theron in a long
shot yeah underrated comedy it's really
hysterical and the romance in it their
chemistry is phenomenal they're great
together
you guys got to watch the long shot if
there's a feel-good movie I could
recommend for you guys right now
definitely a long shot on HBO and then
of course you know Saving Private Ryan I
do say a Private Ryan in the end how can
you feel bad about that not feel good
nineteen
Ethan Holgate thank you so much dude
love love that profile pic thanks for
putting that up there The Lost Boys and
The Breakfast Club feel good to me you
know it's weirdly I lean more towards
Lost Boys on that one I do I always
think of like dark [ __ ] when I think of
Breakfast Club I don't I don't get fuel
that is such a beloved movie and I don't
feel good who had that movies done
weirdly what I think back on when I just
when it floats through my mind I just
remember all the angst that they're all
experiencing yeah I remember who plays
the the bully guy it was his name [ __ ]
ender Lawrence bender no no that guy
wrote Star Wars god I know his name
though Anthony no that's not a nerdy one
go the guy who plays yeah the tough dude
who's like goes on the speech and like
reenacting his dad yelling at him that's
what I think is like oh my god no wonder
this guy's such an [ __ ] it's weird
I've only ever seen him in The Breakfast
Club but I know his name and now I can't
oh you know what let me expand this
question out then while we got this chat
still going um I want to expand this
question out to songs that instantly
help you feel good for me I was just a
give you guys some examples for me I
don't really like this band but I love
this song it's by the killers
I never one of the most acoustic covered
songs you'll ever hear all these things
that I've done absolutely love that song
stand by me specifically the John Lennon
version dancing in the moonlight
specifically the toploader version I
really love a [ __ ] uh you know what
does it for me it's like the old not
many Eminem songs that's there feel good
but the Eminem song that really does it
for me is the song berserk that I got a
major kick out at two
yeah for sure what about you John you
probably have some good feel-good song
feel good too man
the one one song I've had on a lot
lately to feel good too as a song called
humility by Gorillaz and partly why I've
had that song on is because a it's very
summery it's got a really beautiful kind
of pleasant atmosphere but it's also a
song about wanting to be out of
isolation and to connect with people and
so like especially at this moment in
time this came out before this pandemic
even happened but it's appreciated in
feelgood value I think so I'm very true
so that's one song but there will be
more that come to me as time goes yeah
yeah okay small stakes by spoon that's a
good one about like not letting small
stuff you know make you sweat too much
and get you down let's one Oh what
there's a the song that I heard it's
just this is a very specific song that's
the day I realized I was probably in
love with my girlfriend this song came
on the radio never became super popular
but that's even better hit because no
one else is gonna be sharing this safe
by the band bay legends I absolutely
adore that tune and
can't help but think about her whenever
I hear that song absolutely dude there's
a lot of songs by milky chance that I
really love oh yeah I think milky chance
a lot of feel-good a lot of Jack Jones
I still love Jack Johnson tunes they
really put me in a feel-good mood dude
okay so sidebar I am gonna give myself a
little credit because the character's
name was John bender but Nelson Nelson
is the name I could not recall so there
were at the bottom this song is not
necessarily the most like necessarily
upbeat so to speak like it is a little
bit of like a it's a good workout song
there's a song by Asher Roth actually
called Last Man Standing that like when
I need to feel good in the sense of the
like I can really tackle something or
like I need to boost myself up like
that's a good feel good tune yeah fam
Oaks Brian is saying Brian run brilliant
Brian the same Family Guy I've been
watching a lot more Family Guy as of
late well hey Brian the Family Guy that
really does but if I'm the guy on
American Dad and the Simpsons show on
day like wow catching up on Disney Plus
if I just want to feel good
those shows really help out a lot yeah
those are putting some great
recommendations in here in terms of like
like seriously whoever's in this chat
start taking some notes because there's
a lot of great recommendations here if
you're looking to just uplift your
spirits oh yeah Annie Newton and saying
Pride and Prejudice BBC series heard a
lot of great things about that show hmm
some songs get get the best by
AWOLNATION or get passion huh rock
classic movies do you recommend Oh some
feel-good classic recipes gone with the
wind is a grey wanna feel great gone
with the winds a great feel good charade
a streetcar named desire I recovered
from back Sandra's your waterfront
intolerance
Nosferatu in the heat of the night
sallow in the heat of the night is a
terrific movie tour that movie oh but
there are got to be some great old time
comedies man
I'm gonna this is gonna be the most I
google there yeah which one pillow talk
with Dori aqua Doris Day came to me out
of nowhere
dodgeball Oh H said dodgeball absolutely
I'm gonna write so write some of these
down in my phone this is literally going
to be you recommending us I just want to
do is live stream to get some tips Fred
Astaire's there get some dancing into
your life my friends yeah I would also
say yeah let's see uh oh my god oh my
god oh yeah it makes me bleed my nobody
hey Brendan B thank you so much you guys
got the bed we don't have the bed
brought the bandanas and I I feel like
with the amount of time we take through
going through comments and going through
super chats and taking our time with a
lot of these answers you we probably set
this before and then you put this down
here like before we realize you had
already super chatted this but no I'm
sorry we don't have the bandanas at the
moment we'll have the promise next time
okay next week we will have bandanas 200
people are in the room will have them
dinner DC's legends of tomorrow Oh chef
I think the 2019 shaft is a good feel
good movie someone stand right here the
flick and critics where we at pulp
fiction really sure about pulp fiction
Carter real good movie dude I think the
feel-good is too Tarantino gets is
probably Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
and there's some heavy [ __ ] her noble a
good call on a great way to kick the
door in happy happy love to Hawaii Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure that's
another feel-good movie right there
rific call Nightmare Before Christmas
I'd say so I'd say I give it to you
kikuchi films asking yo Gregg and John
how are you guys so sexy it's simple
it's simple
a lot of Rogaine everywhere hmm I still
use we are Harry
I put Rogaine everywhere on my body and
I put it on the cat's too I put it on
John when he's not looking
he's got a hairy back because of it a
lot of Rogaine
and also a lot of fiber if you do take a
lot of fiber and Rogaine combine them
together it's I don't know how to
properly your guts out and grow some
hair but it's it really does cover up a
lot of extra fat so yeah a lot of fiber
and a lot of Rogaine just want to say
yes
I cannot say home alone is a good
feel-good movie nathaniel johnson thank
you so much is that a real photo of you
that is sexy or I love the lighting you
look like you're in double toasted
usually he's in double toasted meets
that John wick averse spirited away any
Studio Ghibli movie have you seen any
Studio Ghibli movies I've seen Princess
Mononoke I've seen spirited away and
I've seen the wind rises and oh oh oh
[ __ ] there's there's an early one that
was before spirited away that has a
character's name in the title and
they're wanting to save these giant bug
creatures I've seen that one too yeah
sounds fun
I've seen four but I haven't seen howls
I haven't seen Totoro there's been a lot
of love for the movie super bad in this
chat so far a lot of love that is an
adventure I didn't feel good yeah
McLovin alone I mean I I will I will say
out of any movie that I've seen where I
would like we're not exactly those two
but I think around like our early
twenties mm-hmm there's that's the only
movie a good thing cover like yeah
that's that's the closest to us like
early 20s Greg and John I would say I'm
like yeah I was definitely like a Jonah
Hill and he was definitely like a
Michael Cera
yeah it's not a one to one but yeah it's
like you were each those guys and then
each of us has a dash of McLovin yeah
I'd say so
but that's the one because it was so
easy to go which one are you yeah here's
one speaking of feel-good music and
movie collision go watch the Irish film
Singh Street because the music in that
film is really great really lively but
also it's really inspiring and really
heartfelt picture Annie so we're gonna
get to your question I just thought of
another one I just thought of another I
start of another feel-good movie that
you wouldn't say is a feel-good movie
but I feel good I feel
endeared by the end of it and that is I
think it's Swedish Swedish or Swiss
Switzerland there's a remake of it
called let me in the original film is
let the right one and we dish seen that
twice both times I like that it's it's a
strange film because it looks like when
you see the trailer it looks like this
like full-blown horror movie but it's
not but I feel good when that movies
that you guys seen that film the
original I think the remakes pretty good
actually Matt Reeves Batman Batman but
it's still on hold but I would I think
let the right one it is a great film
that makes you feel good and you
wouldn't expect that ending mmm all
right we got Carlo okay we got the
disaster artist in here good call DC's
legends of tomorrow again I love Anissa
also Jon watched Ed Wood John Steve you
take this comment John also John I
watched Edie would hug emoji it was
great I liked it a lot I love Tim Burton
so I knew I would love it I'm so glad to
hear that that is my favorite motion
picture why do you love it so much John
tell the camera I love that movie
because it is so many different things
and I love the idea of doing a biopic in
the style of film that person might have
made I think it's one of Johnny Depp's
most Ernest character performances
because it is Falana character but not
in a very obvious type of way there are
so many great side character
performances it's in black and white
which I adore when we're not restricted
to black and white and yeah it tells a
very relatable story that I think any
artist can come to where it's that
conundrum of you want to put your all
and your passion into something even if
it's not that good you know and so I
think it speaks to something that we can
all touch on as creative types but also
it's just so fun it's really indicative
of its time in place and even if it
takes liberties it's a really lively
biopic so yeah I could go on for days
theremin great answer John great answers
all around everyone I'm so proud of
everyone in this chat really you guys
have come a long way the Exorcist
Oh edwood getting a lot of love here
underrated movie Hey Tarantino said it
should have won the either screen player
or picture award that year that
promotion beat it against a Reservoir
Dogs can't remember I don't know if I
could I can't agree with Tarantino I
don't ever agree with Tarantino ever hey
Jenna Randolph how's it going yeah I
guess so
and then oh yes a mr. what happened to
it what was it what was the idea was
sort of my mind just now don't worry
about back there eventually
okay so I have fallen again behind on
the super chest but let's go through
some comments here blues some songs
let's dance by David Bowie yes that is a
good one
Harvey danger flagpole Sitta is a great
song and that holds the test of time and
they've got other good tracks they we
got east start saying you are so
beautiful to me I used to think people
on tick tock were talentless and then I
did that is what I'm getting out of that
I'm not gonna sing post Malone I was
making a sarcastic comment there are
plenty of talented people on take Tong
yeah like I don't know anyone who's on
tick tock I know I friend you have take
Sarah Erik's money's probably good
that's hilarious
oh dude little miss sunshine
Oh a little miss sunshine good a school
of rock is one of my favorite movies and
that's a good one and then John lean
your head hmm okay me names the
Eliminator thank you so much for
contributed super check burnt John Deere
Bernie Bernie Bernie Sanders impression
who by the way is still running for
president he has not endorsed by didn't
I want to make that clear I loved the
movie rat race because of the funny
moment heard him talk in a minute oh
[ __ ] okay wait time any livestreams
hello nice anthis I loved the movie for
young Bernie Sanders was a 1960s Italian
mom is I don't know what he's saying
okay I'm gonna do like a Bernie thing in
my mind like right before I talk turns
and now Pacino so I don't want to go I
love the movie I love the movie right
right
I I'm failing this hard I love the movie
rat raised because of the funny moments
and funny stunts hahaha
have you guys seen it race yeah I love
rat race I think adds a funny mood
actually you know what I would say
that's an underrated comedy mm-hmm that
is a really I think at the time we came
out it was just like ah it's a ripoff of
it's a mad mad world just with a
different title but no I think it's more
than that I think it does its own thing
I mean similar plot set up Barry it's a
king but also I mean a lot of the
details of the set up are very different
you know I remember any Nazi encounter
Mints and it's mad mad world oh yeah
yeah I mean it's definitely updated to
be a broad comedy but it's weird
well I don't necessarily look back on
that movie as like a terrific film that
didn't receive the respect it deserves
I think it is like a lot more fun than
it's like I see it reminds you of
Flatliner Thank You Bernie Alvarado by
the way you always here Bernie Alvarado
and hey what's your cat's name
flatlander 80 set off thank you that's
such an old man big contribution they
need to see you again dude yeah thank
you but I think in your I mean it's a
thank you it's really a lot of money huh
thank you but the I want to say thank
you in the way how sam said in a recent
episode on supernatural that we just put
up on patron thank you really thank you
I do like Keanu Reeves now do it like
Bernie thank you really thank you now
he'll play Bernie in a biopic how Baggio
could definitely play Bernie if Larry
Dave is not gonna do it
Pacino should happy saturday handsome
men when i want to check out what i like
to binge watch ion flux MTV series pH
Beverly Hills 90210 and Daria feel-good
movies
are you doing the pretty standard
because I just want to redeem myself and
it's not going well sister I've never
been kissed don't tell Mom the
babysitter's dead sister act don't we
know someone who worked on don't tell
Mom the babysitter's dead I feel like we
do this came up recently and no it's
never been kissed yeah oh man no one had
ever kissed you Barrymore and so she got
a makeover no but got hot finally that's
how that became Beverly Hills 90210 do
it your thing thank you by the way you
are a handsome man yourself trust me if
you were in the room right now all eyes
would be on you thank god you're not
because you would just steal the
spotlight from all our Rogaine and fiber
that we've been taking a flat liner you
know your Kong reminds me of a trailer I
just saw for a Netflix thing when we
were done watching Supernatural have you
heard of this like weird Temptation
Island [ __ ] on Netflix it's like number
5 in the US right now what the [ __ ] is
it called too hot for sex or something -
you're too hot first yes it's basically
like you get like this like a bunch of
hot ass [ __ ] on an island and
then and then the whole point is they
just can't bone each other and they lose
money if they do any type of sexual
encounter and I'm like how can that be
I am so told when many many years about
any sexually yeah I could definitely win
that battle I am so so so torn on that
concept because half of me goes what and
the other half goes that's a very smart
game show idea that's gonna make all of
us go let's get that sexual tension
going watch that show going stop [ __ ]
each other I know you know we'll create
this inner conflict because you'll be
simultaneously going guys don't do it
well thank you fly lighter
ooh Donald Duck John redoing your Donald
Duck impression I can't I can do that
know that Donald Duck boys where's our
handsome baby hand me the baby wipe
yourself secret life of walter mitty
oh is that yes
based on the book short story etc of the
same name Donald have I ever done it on
the blog voice I don't know it's a
really hard voice to do I remember when
John and I were really young and I was
your face out of the [ __ ] thing god
damn it I remember I was really young I
was I was sleeping over at John's house
and Ben Stiller did some random drama
and we didn't know it was a drama we
thought Ben Stiller it's probably some
funny [ __ ] ends I mean it's hardcore
drama to which I don't remember the
title and Ben Stiller's opening scene is
some girl just hardcore riding him
remember that I do I was like what the
hell is his remake the whole movie all
they're talking about is sex the whole
time yes it was it was one of those
comedies that managed to be completely
just a lot of fun racing and unpleasant
look at what it was unfunny and
unpleasant The Heartbreak Kid who some
good song recommendations were seeing
here in the chat will go back to the
super chest a second post Malone
sunflower good call Bob Marley three
little birds you're the one that I want
from grease oh you know what I want you
know what I really love you know I
really love youth of the nation we are
we are the youth of the nation I just
feel like if I could learn how to sing
that would be the best like [ __ ] uh
that'd be the best karaoke song it would
be gratifying if you could do the rap
part like last day for the wisdom alive
do the singing part like if you can do
both of those all managed so sex and if
you could sing your own backup vocals
was he doing that Tod the last I checked
still exist we haven't missed anyone
here Yeah right we're going through this
in order yes okay twist and shout from
the Beatles good one I want to hold your
hand by the Beatles I think is a really
good feel good song very good hey we're
catching up with a chat a little bit
we got Keane Lagerfeld
same Flintstones casting David Harbour
as Fred is actually not a bad pick Kevin
James is Barney also not a bad pig Reese
Witherspoon as Wilma Katy Perry has been
Katy Perry as Betty yeah and Ricky
Gervais is as guru good calls all right
hey the thing is though like they could
easily reboot the Flintstones any minute
now because it's been so many years
since we've thought about it at all
totally totally John all right back in
the middle all right guys all right
uh kiss seven seven thank you so much
for contributing dude my feel-good movie
is the other thank you I've been shrunk
my Olivia's not into Will Ferrell and
I've been and I'll blame her I met a lot
of people just don't like Will Ferrell
movies I've really been trying to get
her to watch the other guys it's a
constant battle to try to get her
watching it's the true test of our
relation but then every time she's like
fine I'll give it a chance I do this I'm
kind of weird you won't like it
you gotta put on a day where you guys
neither of you care what you watch it's
it's both on other guys and Breaking Bad
anytime she's like fine let's try it
it's it's just like abrasive attitude of
like fine hmm I'm like I feel like
you're truly open thanks for all your
great work I watched the real rejects
since I was 12 and I'm still here 18 we
were doing this for six years
is that crazy somebody just sent us an
Instagram well thanks for watching for
so long buddy appreciate it Ethan
Holgate Trey Parker's Orgazmo hilarious
movie Havasu nut
I have you did you like it yeah I mean
you know it's exactly
what you you you look at the trailer and
the cover and it's exactly what you're
getting into but for what it is I
laughed yeah fair enough it's it's not
one that I have like an intense
association with but I watched I was
like I see what's to be enjoyed here on
like a midnight on Comedy Central kind
of way guys I'm gonna shout someone out
especially right now
her name's Janice Gerry what Jenice was
our we did improv it so we were younger
yeah none of those skills are truly
shining through tonight due to mood
experiences prior leading into this but
anytime we've been good at improv
it's all thanks to this woman right here
so Jenice thank you for timing in there
watching office space tonight yeah
Mike and Dave me what Arrested
Development I haven't seen the latest
season I think there was a lot of bad
lean into the latest season based off of
that weird interview that got really
popular out of weird tension I wow I
forgot all about but do you know do you
know a great podcast that I listened to
that always puts me in a good mood Conan
O'Brien needs a friend that is the truth
yeah one podcast I'd like to get into
like actually guest star on one day be
Conan O'Brien needs a friend
undoubtably called that all right so
what do we got here I love that there's
somebody shouting out the Phantom with
Billy Zane yes Jon get rid of scooch in
buddy Lou I'm scooched for Jared Penn
for Matthew home Matthew Holmes want to
feel strange watch MIT Samar I feel like
that can you feel good movie in some
ways depending on which person you
identify with yes yeah if you identify
florins Pugh maybe have you guys have
you guys seen Tucker and Dale vs. evil
that's a really great feel good movie to
me that is a lovely office space is a
good one the office is a great feel good
show
dude what we do in the shadows on both
counts that is a feel-good movie and
from what I understand a feel-good show
as well now oh sorry
Ozark is like the most talked-about show
right now does not seem feel good but
certainly use quality all right Jared
Penn thank you so much my
dude padalecki first off thank you for
being awesome and keeping me entertained
during these hard times no problem
my favorite feel food movie is Rudy Rudy
carpet watching him and get fat by the
end of that watching Sean Astin prepare
for saying yeah he just he prepared for
the role bite by not playing and not
practicing and not know it's really is I
feel like sports movies you get a lot of
feel-good movies out of there right do
they make is there a genre of sports
movie that isn't intrinsically tied to
some kind of triumph of the human spirit
is there just like a character study
sports movie where things don't turn out
well ah fair point I don't I don't think
so I can't think of one that's a that's
a good call of a sports movie though for
sure like Rudy especially has the chance
that we like people use the Rudy chant
to make other people in real life feels
I feel like of all the sports movies
like that as a terrific call guys I want
you to know we are going in order of the
super chat so some people think they're
super chats are being missed we have
this up here because this is the exact
order all them come in through and to be
fair we're not skipping anyway yes
that's the way I roll what screens here
for those who we can't just put up as a
graph yeah so we're letting you know
we're just being fair to everyone and
that's the way it goes but sorry if we
haven't gotten to yours yet but I
promise you will
Brendan B thank you ratatouille always
makes me feel better the food and the
amazing animation of Paris or everything
chefs kiss ratatouille underrated ass
Pixar movie I think underrated so much
that it made so much money became so
beloved in fact we had a movie trivia
Schmo down questioned about a reason
I'll go check that out on when it
finally comes out yeah anyone can it's
not out yet match no well it's not
anything that pertains to the magic well
you might be given too many hints based
off of the way you're saying it John
thinking back to the film itself let's
see here a harvey danger flagpole let's
go what we're back yeah
flagpole Sitta love that song baby
driver soundtrack is getting a lot of
love in this chat wedding crashers
another great call here yeah alright so
what do we got here
Bernie's back alright I'm gonna this is
the third time's a charm
alright once you find the thing to flash
on no all right no it's out there
alright John do it
I feel good movie is national lampoon's
vacation because of the funny lines at
40 moments Chevy Chase I have in fact
I've seen vacation and a like to a few
Christmases ago I saw a Christmas
vacation for the first time so I'm
severely late to that party
John you [ __ ] up man we I just said
this whole thing about us going in order
and you skip this one right here
Brendan V yeah Wow
I thought you had it flashed oh no John
don't blame me I blame you for I it's my
fault if things go right I get the
credit when things go wrong you get the
blame
yeah yeah I met yeah I messed that up I
know I did you have to point it out what
are you talking about Oh question you
said multiple superchef that's why God
confuse me the most messed up man yeah I
just did that I don't want the blame
that's just plain and simple
we'll take take the blame for both I've
been watching my loved ones lame for
daily press conferences about the
coronavirus and I've learned a thing or
two about how to handle this well yeah
because you know what you've been doing
here is great it reveals right it's my
praise all right and if it goes wrong
it's just the liberal media everyone
else's fault
so let's correct this Brendan be just
warning y'all said another super Chad
that's a fan do you guys remember you
now in patreon love you guys of course I
remember you from you now Tim failed an
app that we tried for like a hot minute
and was like this sucks this is live
stream somewhere else
hey YouTube doesn't sweet cuz I'm still
surprised that somebody else beat them
to that punch Thank You Brendon thank
you for sticking with us for so thank
you for contributing so much here thank
you for being so kind
John bring bandanas next week wash
and dry them before you come over dude
they're gonna be so clean that you're
not gonna want to take him off all right
Aneesa Olivia my girl is also a
feel-good movie as well and also any
John Hughes movie even though I know you
all don't enjoy I never said I don't
enjoy John Hughes I mean you know he I
just said he has some films now get a
little bit of backlash for team
coming-of-age films not aged the
greatest yeah that's not to say that you
can't still love the John Hughes you
know am i I don't know what my girl is
um you know I'd know it what it is but I
can't really get in depth about it
because I've not seen it it's a good
call I'm sure I would assume Oh can't
take my eyes off you by Frankie Valli's
TM set it in the chat great call great
great call call now Jenna I know you've
been saying we skipped your super chat
but look we just got to it my dear
right here gonna highlight right here
hey guys I love you we love you too
Jenna I haven't been able to do patron
lately
that's okay have you ever seen the anime
bungo stray dogs have not seen it it's
been highly recommended as a matter of
fact we are about to be fully caught up
with my hero academia so we are shopping
around some ideas of what the next anime
show is that we're gonna be covering in
the meantime stray dogs on the list
might just do a raffle and a poll you
make sure to vote Jenna yeah but I
appreciate you contribute to the chat I
hope you're being safe I hope your dad
is doing well too much love to you
you've been an incredible supporter of
us for so long thank you so much sorry
it took us so long to get her answer the
question but we also just don't want and
I know I'm there's no disrespect to
anyone a lot of people kind of just only
go through the super chat we also like
to make sure we're reading the regular
comments as well a little bit everybody
a little bit of everybody you know we
know now that we don't want to just play
some pure favoritism here just some
favoritism you know that's the way it
goes
you know like someone dryer just said
are you reading any coming yeah we are
so let's go back to here but Thank You
Janet Jared pen again thank you so much
Thank You Jared sorry for the type of
obvious I meant good in my message
another feel-good movie I loved is up
you guys Rock I like that you penalized
yourself the only feel good part of up
for me is the first 10 minutes yeah I
felt like that old [ __ ] was holding him
back from pursuing his real dreams so
when she died and went finally he can go
traveling to something he really wants
like hang out with a little boy on a fun
little adventure that woman was holding
him back and feel goodness kicked in
around when she kicked the can that's
all I'm gonna say I can't answer that
but a flawless take a flawless take on
that ha we got Kiki Gardner in the chat
which is not a super chap out of every
what's going on you're in the government
hot rod that's a movie I walked out of
and then when who you know what thinking
back that first 20 minutes was kind of
funny let me go back and I laughed my
ass off not rot just called err
Pineapple Express
amen to that yes no no I saw an early
screening waited a year for it to come
out to John opening night and he loved
it next Halloween we were Seth Rogen and
James Franco from that movie role that
picture oh that was no oh what the hell
man I said I was gonna bring it up in
this chat I know that's my failure and
the funny thing your fault not me we're
shutting down the [ __ ] governors and
the fun part of that costume for y'all
playing along at home is that I was Seth
Rogen and you were James improv wig okay
oh okay oh yeah so scourge a 99
Paddington wanted to and to when an Lucy
turns up I totally agree I've never seen
the movie I totally agree with you say
I'll say whatever you want if you super
shadows so thank you so much
I really guy B there are a few like
there are lots of movies I need to see
to feel better about myself but I feel
like it's a true failure that I have
seen neither paddington film for just
how much like purity I've heard yeah
you've let us down big time yeah yeah no
no this is seriously another one of my
shortcomings a Wonder Woman I guess I
guess I would be a feel-good movie that
no man's land scene just really makes
you like it's just t really it's
inspirational tears you know it's very
inspirational tears let's see here
Philly g philip defranco feel good thank
you so much dude it's a big contribution
Thank You Philly I felt the Franco says
what's up you beautiful sons of [ __ ]
and you [ __ ] [ __ ] feel-good movies
shift The Princess Bride feel the dreams
keep it fury Willy Wonka Amelie and big
trouble a little China that's my way of
like how that's my rhythm a Philip
DeFranco because it's obvious that he's
like he has semi of a script in front of
him and then he's like cuts it in a
certain way his editor does to make it
seem like it's just like it's really
smooth what I'm like I know what it's
like to read from a script and edit just
a little bit of Philip defranco's a fake
fake journalism fake actually he's
probably the most trusted guy in
journalism I could think of on YouTube
I'd say on the youtubes yeah but I think
just generally speaking I think he's
great at what he does because Philip
DeFranco will he'll he knows how to
insert his opinion but still make
everything fair and open it up to like
both sides I think that's what's really
good about the way he does it as opposed
to right wing and left media it's it's
it's like he knows how to stay his
stance but also or his take but then but
not make it the whole point of the show
yeah I still long let's do a video
honest I'm just saying good things we
could be doing one of his little guest
intros or something someday if you play
your cards right feel-good movies chef
haven't seen it Princess Bride is a
great
Cole princess brides one of the best
movies of all time that's just my
personal opinion Willy Wonka I would say
Charlie and Chocolate Factory everyone
prefers that one
Cuban fury what about balls of fury you
see that in palm it's funny I thought it
was funny
Amelie what about harmony hammer Big
Trouble in Little China
rmally I think that Dwayne Johnson
reboots gonna totally outdo it that's
right that's what we need right now but
the Thank You Philly Philip DeFranco for
us here Brendan B we accidentally
skipped and went to you sorry for
playing favoritism there did not intend
that I hate you Anisa thank you again
some like it hot
yep see singing in the oh great call
that is a great Olivia wouldn't love you
she really would Wayne's World
oh great one feel-good movies we belong
together
Ritchie Valens and drama de gorillas
feel-good samba dude Anisa you and John
Rocco on a date I'm just saying you guys
got to go on a date John you got to take
her to like chuck e cheese or something
you know some something great that women
love like super classy like laser tag
some the shows you really pay you gotta
take anise on a proper date yeah you
know you know rent out the back room
where they have like the little birthday
parties you know we'll have like our own
unlimited laser tag go to blockbuster
rent a DVD or something really Asia so
we're the last blockbusters you got it
to it man blasting and drama all the way
up we got Kiki here who just recently
saw die hard for the first time after
hearing about it
well done her whole life it was awesome
a sound like heard about this movie
called die hard son a crazy guy in a
building company you're trying to rescue
save his marriage suddenly terrorists
break what are the odds right Christmas
the phantom Pete Ramirez the Phantom
Billy Zane no one talks about the
Phantom enough no one talks about the
Phantom and the shadow
enough those are the best comic book
movies i watch growing huh I read this
whole article I need to watch the
documentary I wrote I watched his whole
article read saw about the the death of
Superman movie the keanu and a counter
is on the Nicolas Cage 1 and Tim Burton
yep and I'm like why are we talking
about releasing that cut maybe because
they didn't film anything but you know
documentary talking about filming that
movie but mr. Sunday movies did that
funny but it was also like kind of cool
claymation video of the rise of
Skywalker Colin Trevorrow cut oh yeah I
would love for them to do one for the
the death of Superman one let that be I
think there's something special be done
there for mr. Sunday movies of doing
just a whole bunch of those the the what
is or the movies that never got made
their sequels I never got done I think
he should do those those would be a lot
of fun love that mr. Sunday also by the
way noticing you Jenna and noticing uh
whoever commented right after you that
you also want it to be noticed you're
both being noticed yes she can whoever
come in to do you about uh demigod Emma
Gorgon boy good but I haven't seen good
boys yet but I hear it's pretty great a
lot of recommendations yeah ooh
Matthew home oh my god now yeah thank
you for bringing it up you you kind of
look like you could be a really like hot
charming guy or an uber driver who
kidnaps people I love that a factor look
man but I would never say that to your
face in real life no I'm just saying
that because over than that I know you
could whup my ass in person you look
like a young Kevin Bacon to me I'm
saying this over the youth like Kevin
Bacon meet Zac Efron actually yeah and
then mix in just a little bit of the
lead singer from either fun or Interpol
and you got it
and video games that make you feel good
god of glory uh god oh god of war I'm
almost done with it I got two chapters
left on God of War is it making you feel
good it really is look at that alright
yeah um feel good video game man you
know it's a great one
a little big plan it's a great one snake
on the old phone hold on a second
there's a great feel good game Katamari
is a lot of fun just roll up a whole
will of world of yourself um I'd say I
don't know any feel-good games i animal
cross I love like the dark ass games
like animal cross animal cross or the
Sims remember the Sims when you were in
the Middle's are you guys who here is
old enough to remember playing The Sims
in middle school hmm and being up all
night entering that [ __ ] Chico to
give yourself a million dollars having a
wife and a kid I didn't know gay
marriage in that game yeah can you can
you like kiss of another guy or be a
girl kiss another girl I lived a lot of
fantasies through that Sims a lot of
sided advances oh man I lost a lot of
sleep and did not and all I thought
about when I was in school was going
home and playing The Sims if I'm not
mistaken the original Sims or something
is made some kind of resurgence in
online like gaming stores and so has
roller coaster tycoon they got a of that
phone app game out now yeah at that
Lauren Martinez Thank You Lauren love
your profile pic yeah I'm trying to
learn how to compliment women on the
internet without crossing into creep
territory and I feel like that is a
great prelude into doing this well let's
see how it goes let's get some
compliments going and then and then I
got more of a finer line - I got a ride
because I'm in a relationship right so I
don't want to ever do something where it
looks like I'm coming on to the person
so it's like how do you appropriately
compliment like did you know gentlemen
complimenting a lady without hating on
him I find that at all like father like
you could do it it'd be like a little
flirty I can't do that that's
inappropriate well this is where other
adjectives come in because I think if
you say like you know if you just said
like oh that's a lovely avatar you know
like lovely isn't necessarily like I am
directly indicating my attraction to you
specifically you know or like delightful
or let me give it a shot
not to come across like a creepy pervert
who you want to talk about on Twitter
and cancel me one day I just want to say
that's a lovely profile avatar Photo you
got that was felt like you were talking
to me suppose that make me feel good or
Frasier and Cheers
no you got decades of material there
yeah Thank You Laura Martinez actually
I've seen some I have not seen much of
cheers in my life but in the past year
is when I have seen literally every
episode I've ever seen in two years and
it is a lovely it is a little very
delightful show Susannah came in the
chat here to say today I watched x-men
Dark Phoenix didn't add on to that she
said I lied on maybe warranting
situation was going fine then I watched
execute Phoenix now I can't wait for the
quarantine situation to comment again if
that made you feel good or not Marvel's
runaways hey that was an awesome show
Greg what was his name Greg Greg
whatever sulking Gregg Sulkin handsome
gentleman were you there the day I met
him I was yeah it's spiced I remember he
called them he's like you're you're so
funny you you're timing that's all I
remember
everything else I was owned out yeah
yeah all that part where he is like give
me a number so I can get you roll this
new show who is a long smile and orgasm
to my pants as he looked at me see I can
make that comment about him because he's
a straight man and gay guy jokes are
funny cuz he's straight cuz it's yeah if
that was a wall area it would just be
like why are you sharing this
information don't do that
another feel good show Adventure Time or
what's a great feel good this is around
the mark in the live stream where Greg
and John and her delusional territory
feel good notice the trajectory of how
this goes I really noticed how - the
trajectory of this it always goes a
start off yeah positive energy we're
really really into this and we're
actually fairly sharp and we're making
sure this ten to the Super shadow
scented the comments
not lose track of anything and then
about the 30 to 40 minute mark energy
starts to go like a little bit down and
we're like oh no I mean people are kind
of bored at the kind of not interested
well we're having fun though let's do
this might get you to get your head out
of the negative thinking stay positive
what's going on my end the hour mark I'm
like oh I'm starting to feel a second
wind coming then around the hour and a
half part I go okay I'm I presenter like
it's stupid shits and start coming out
of my mouth I just know it don't worry
that third one's coming an hour to
someone is spamming 2001 a Space Odyssey
as hangar 1
is that a feel-good film it depends on
your perspective you know feel-good is
subjective sure that true that and hey I
mean catharsis sometimes you got to
watch something that is reminiscent of
your situation to get it so I feel ya
John yes share ah we did it perfect
perfect face slam perfect faceplant
faceplant
Galen somewhere this guy
someone saw eight-mile recently now you
got a great you got a great beard did if
I make if you're a guy and I make fun of
you that's only because I'm jealous I
want to make that clear the great
outdoors compliment if I can't man you I
have the best time to tune in on all our
livestream is gonna have they've been on
for an hour and a half
all right now first half hour or the
hour and a half that's when they're like
they don't give two [ __ ] anymore the
great outdoors batteries not included
and the natural candy and Aykroyd best
comedies you in a movie the great
outdoors perfect those are some solid
recommendations dude ah
rest in peace John Candy rest in peace
John Candy and D Conan O'Brien talks a
lot about John Candy on his podcast dan
Aykroyd I just hear nothing but weird
things about the guy he's got skull
vodka and alien theories what's weird
about that
I'm not gonna ESA on this John good
Jenice is watching and she's friends
with Danny
Jenice our old improv teacher yes and on
yourself there thank you for joining us
Diary of a Wimpy Kid Icarus yes please
mash them up someone misses our old set
up from the old house which ones go get
the old house there's been like four
news I constantly changed the set up
depending on where I'm living
I know if we found like an old plate we
could just start green screening in the
old set because of this one comment that
all it takes let's make one tiny bit of
[ __ ] up with the lighting on the
green-screen and you got a shitty ass me
dude Susan Diaz shouts out for killing
it on these mashup titles okay are you
taking I'm just being so polish boys I'm
gonna get on the phone hello
yeah it's me I can talk I'm not doing
any central intelligence Kevin Hart the
rock [ __ ] funny ass movie have you
seen it no I just went with you to get
paintballed you didn't actually get
painful I know I just observed man that
great food that day remember they took
us at Disneyland they took us to the
blue blue and I want everyone to know
right now when Studios want you to
really recommend their movie in their
home video releases they hook it up with
a lot of [ __ ] food they buy your
affection they buy your affection I mean
I haven't seen central intelligence but
is great I mean good call
they say the key to comedy is write and
say the things that make you laugh that
will not get me that movie was on my
mind earlier in this conversation when
you brought up Seth Rogen
honestly the the trope in 5050 when he
starts dating his therapist that kind of
got on my nerves I was like of course
he's gonna do everything else I really
loved about it but that part of it as
charming as Anna Kendrick is and is
underrated of an actor she is have you
seen her on the kwibi app no we got a
free trial neighbors that's a great one
teen Titanic yeah totally
do you want teen Titanic that'd be so
good you get the kids from stranger
things of it you combine them in one
movie they're on the Titanic oh my god
please unleash that trend on us where
you take popular dramas and make the kid
version what ever happened to Ryan right
cancel culture
I miss Jon short hair Oh Jon time to cut
your hair again Jon used to have spiky
hair when we were younger I can find you
a picture of it priceless spiky hair and
braces for I think 21 years yeah you did
have braces for too long of a time I had
braces for like most of junior high and
a lot of elementary school that's why
he's so confident
[Laughter]
Niraj Krishnan someone finally said
Space Jam my favorite feel-good music
right now
and Rogers Prayer recommendations by the
way SATA I'm along by the Indian by an
Kai owned by Indian me okay I have no
idea who these guys are
but they sound like a great band because
you're recommending the Mirage feel-good
movie Full Monty
good call Jon are you on your phone I'm
looking something up right you're
texting people I'm also texting oh my
god can I read your text as a private is
it personal
let's see dramatic your pictures are
ready for hanging and Diana is ordering
pizzas tonight
sorry I've gotten like three phones am i
able to have some of these pizzas yeah
come on by just we'll toss them out the
windows the front door to you and you
know if you need any napkins you want
the paper where's your family getting
pizzas from probably
jon's you know Papa John did some pretty
horrible things recently
whenever will know the Humphrey family's
ports Monticello and we are resting into
the worst I had Papa John's last week so
you're part of the problem they lower
their prices and [ __ ] what yeah but it's
true though man man you know people are
problematic and as long as you
acknowledge that you can eat the pizza
all right guys we're gonna go through
these super chats right now and that's
what we got left I just showed it on
screen and then I'm gonna get John home
to his family
now dude we got another three hours the
way we've done the social distancing the
quarantine rules like I've seen other
channels we're in the same room Grande
we're not six feet apart right now but
we also have a lot less people we're
dealing with the quarantine rules no
less than ten - less than ten people in
the room and every day it's been John
who lives at home with three other
people who are only in home the whole
time pretty much right and nobody
believe I have masks and masks several
and I have a word bathroom and I have
like condoms that's not actually several
gloves and and I they were very like we
are super anal I have so many things to
wipe down everything you see here
Olivia's when John leaves the room I
kind of get the impression she she does
it out of spite actually now I believe
that I'm a dirty person he was huge on
leaves
she's like [ __ ] wipes down everything
aggressively and I have John take off
his shoes before he comes inside I have
my own hand towel for Washington yeah
you're very anal about those things
yeah and but ya know we we never have
the one time we had more than John here
was when Dan randomly showed up and
stood in the back even and we were like
what the [ __ ] what yeah so we're pretty
anal about everything right now pretty
heinous things in California are looking
up
actually in the quarantine situation
projected numbers about to go down
I'm feeling good I know we have decent
leadership in California
okay Thank You Niraj appreciate that
Bernie Alvarado my cat's name
puh pause pronounced poo pause that is a
delightful name and that's why that cat
has that expression why the [ __ ] did you
name me poo pause damn you Bernie huh
thank you dude thanks dad
Anissa Olivia hmm you all should real
thank you for the super chat my dears
there were some the yellow ones and the
blue ones I don't know and the green I
wonder if they're either by they must be
by like denomination or something you
all should really react to Jensen Ackles
scene I've watched some of the videos on
my own time Jensen Ackles is a fantastic
singer dad was a Dirk but I wanted to be
him Fuli G see you thank you so much
really
singing in the rain Charlie Chaplin
films clue best-in-show Mallrats Goonies
coming to America those are all great
recommendations I've only seen like two
Chaplin films but I've seen the rest you
recommend it for Goonies and coming to
America and clue I've seen them all
thank you blue is a good white singing
in the rain yes Charlie Chaplin go watch
like like modern times the Great
Dictator or something like great
dictators magical movie but uh
best-in-show speaking of Christopher
guest's I just watched a movie I'd had
no idea was a Christopher Guest joint
called the big picture from 1989 with
Kevin Bacon Verizon movie as well as
like movies about moviemaking but uh
it's pretty delightful too so just a
piggyback there yesh snaps documentary
was the one about that Superman lives
Scott Welsh is saying here J George is
saying I feel like watching some
homeless guys on the streets begging for
some coins and donors are called patreon
I think what Jay George said in the in
the comments on the super chat in the
comments he said I feel like watching
some homeless guys on the streets
begging for some coins and donors are
called patreon OSE I think what he meant
to say is I feel like I'm watching some
homeless guys on the streets begging for
some coins and donors are called patreon
I was about to say you could you could
just go do that but then that would be
crappy if you just look at them yeah you
know like you should help her or engage
at least talk I just didn't want you to
sound like an idiot
yeah yeah let's go back to the Super
chats let's go back to the love shall we
om u.s. is asking really fast Hans
Zimmer or John Williams I would say John
Williams to iconic of a man bull to
iconic man and more range in Hans Zimmer
gotta give it to him that's probably
fair I think at the moment I'll just go
Zimmer just to be dead just to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's ya Jack Scott
Pilgrim though good call over there hey
Katie Henderson so scared June 1999
coming to America to be loved
oh what a feeling mmm are they still
making that's equal they are that's
right Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
they're bumped into them on set mm-hmm
coming number 2 America finally getting
them back together after the first
coming to America the first time they'll
be on screen together again
who is Will Smith Freddy Murphy and who
else Freddy Murphy yeah Eddie Murphy
Eddie mercury and Freddy Murphy the
delusional part of legend I feel like
I'm watching homeless guys on the street
you call the people give them money
patience we should go outside and just
start begging talk about Freddy Murphy's
and
Arsenio Hall god damn it and impossible
to flub name
unlike Freddy Murphy Matthew Holmes is
the same feel-good show full house
that's a great call
there but you know what else is a really
feel good show fuller house that's even
better you know I'm I did not grow up on
Saved by the Bell
but I want to say to you Matthew Holmes
but your where your a comment made me
think of thank you for the super chat by
the way maybe think of the reboot
trailer which I watched because NBC
blocks a reflecting thing so I was like
I'm just gonna watches oh then I can
watch that show look surprisingly I'm
honestly kind of excited to see how it
turns out it's not a it's not a oh we
skip the super chat it's not a full
reboot it's not a live studio audience
okay single camera feels like I think
it's from someone who worked on 30 rock
and it kind of has that vibe but no it
looks like a good way to update it I
feel like I'd be way better than doing a
live studio audience yes because that
just feel that makes it feel weird and
dated yeah when you're bringing it back
after all these years granted Will &
Grace is pulling off wonderfully but but
specifically like say by show like Saved
by the Bell or these other ones like
fuller house and the [ __ ] Cory and
Topanga one that was called the [ __ ]
coriander saying all the boy's life Boy
Meets World and Girl Meets World
oh yeah we are getting delusional cuz I
was about to say you want to feel good
here's a here's a web recommendation
Funny or Die has a series I think it's
hilarious called Zack Morris is trash or
they're just these little video essays
of somebody breaking down Saved by the
Bell episodes but through the scope of
the fact that Zack is a terrible person
doing terrible things he was friends you
know never learns anything you know from
funnier died the thing that never fails
to make me laugh is the James Franco
acting class videos you do with his
brother sniff jackets that was my
introduction at dave franco was it was
that with it were those sketches and so
I always thought I'd just see Dave
Franco's James Franco's brother and a
part of me kind of always does but yeah
but I think dave Franco is really funny
but that was if you haven't see the
James Franco acting
acting class on Funny or Die acting
school oh my god
connecting with James Franco hysterical
stuff mm-hmm
James Franco here's a great guy yeah
yeah he's never done anything wrong
mmm-hmm
all right you don't all prefer his
brother now and this I'm gonna combine
your two right here thank you for
contributing some you're so sweet you
talked to me on Instagram after hearing
the most recent news of thinking it's
incredible you're always incredible but
especially lately you been there like
you've been so sweet a movie I know is
going to be a feel-good in the heights
since I love the musical did you ever
see the trailer John I know Greg teared
up Greg a feel-good song so no one told
you life was gonna be this way that's
that's pts Ross got the clap that makes
sense so the only two who don't have it
or Phoebe and Joey in the heights in the
heights that dad that sure they made me
cry a lot whatever I see on Rotten
Tomatoes
what's the Blake Lively movie called the
rhythm the rhythm section the rhythm
section whenever I go on rotten tomatoes
and I see the rhythm section I always
think it's in the heights for some
reason I think III associate that with
the title of rhythm section within the
heights for some reason no no real
correlation and some always like ah too
bad it's got terrible reviews and I and
I never go back until someone brings up
the title in the heights and I go oh
yeah it's a different movie yeah don't
worry
Manuel is still a treasure until proven
otherwise did you ever see that trailer
I've only seen clips of it like which
the corpus of the trailer only a handful
of disparate seconds of the trailer now
I should actually go watch it
ah too bad John I know I'm failing this
live chat right now friends in the
office were feel-good shows started
he'll I mean we can't talk about
spider-man ps4 guys
spider-man ps4 is a
using game beat it recently and I gotta
tell you cuz some people are talking
around the chat I really hope that we
get some Miles Morales aspire man in
that game they get play as him let me
just say this if people are able to you
if you're able to play ass Miles Morales
before he spider-man in the spider-man
ps4 a game if you don't get access to
play as him as spider-man in the via in
the next one I'm gonna be very annoyed
yes he's ridiculous why would you not
get what are you doing John oh I thought
we had caught up again but maybe no no
we're never caught up on these at the
end
so Mimi am thank you so much my dear me
me me me am not to sound creepy or come
across like a pervert or perhaps get
involved in a lawsuit but I love your
avatar mm-hmm yeah it's delightful in
fact I was noticing it on patreon thanks
for the earth gang recommend woman
that's a compliment movement dude I got
a shout out Susanna and the chat really
fast anemia Susanna you've been killing
it in the end
Susanna DSU you've got the most in her I
think people are interacting with you
more than they're interacting with us
right you're killing it
we're gonna find a way to patch you into
the loo next live stream with you
fleabag and shits Creek both shits Creek
shits Creek is fun I'm not all the way
caught up but that's plunger I have not
gotten a flea bag where shits Creek is
it that I feel like more it's not like a
Canadian show originally it maybe maybe
because I know a lot of the sctv folks
are from camp I think it started off as
a Canadian before it came to America for
song lean on me or just the two of us
alright Paul
yeah no I think just the two of us I
think of mini me in Dodgers I'm ashamed
a little bit but I think of Will Smith's
take on the song ha ha ha ha tom job to
be a good dad you've got so much more
stuff than I had and to be honest I
thought that was Will Smith's original
song hey longest time before
was that and and the wild wild west
refrain yeah I never I've heard the
original at the gas station last year
and I was like oh they ripped off the
wah wah so you can't say your first
thoughts on the internet no because then
you'll find out that you know the law
else wrote soft-sell live streams are
always a good idea else wrote Tainted
Love who Archer and that's another great
show thank you mother
J jorts the same bilberry and what about
Bob and Groundhog Day hmm oh yeah
Groundhog Day especially ooh uh somebody
clarify the real-life meaning of
Groundhog Day because I swear that
groundhog said we were getting spring
and it's been winter as [ __ ]
since like all the beginning of the year
so demagogue and boy two in the chata
same baby daddy who's your baby daddy me
or John because if it's not me I'm gonna
be offended cuz you're a guy and usually
the gay guys yeah we can't break this
precedence we can't break this the woman
loved John the gay guys love grass plain
and simple mm-hmm it shows in the
numbers not YouTube analytics have shown
us the women prefer Joe hates you they
have a sexual attraction it's a weird
[ __ ] analytic they added in their new
creator studio plan the gay community
really seems to like this Anisa liver
both your smiles make my heart smile
Wow why wouldn't with so many viewers I
don't know the [ __ ] just happened
Thank You Brendan V you're so sweet dude
so sweet we should follow each other on
social media Brendan be you yeah you're
gonna fall you've unlocked an
achievement people look at who follows
oh well this Brendan viga you must be
worth falling straight 2007 in the great
Muppet Caper or some more feel-good
movies not in the Muppets very much
hairspray though that's a good one as
far as TV shows a prostate the nanny and
Golden Girls yes I'm very gay okay then
John you got to read this and the most
flamboyant stereotypical gay guy voice
possible go I'm gay don't be offensive
don't be offensive what are you doing
hair spray see here's the crossroads and
this joke or do I subvert the church
I'll just do a little bit of probably so
who cares man I you know what I've
realized this this week and you have
helped me just solidify some time I'm
gonna have to watch the Golden Girls at
least a little bit it's it's withstood
the test of time
why'd you react so heavily to the whole
rzj thing
what are you does he laughed his ass off
the whole point is to go oh that's oh
that's normal whatever it doesn't matter
to me why'd you smell attention to me
you look like an [ __ ] John Brandon
I'm sorry for him okay
are you gay we've never met okay guys
prove it how can I tell any remarks that
have been made in jest ice know that we
love you and they're not trying to look
horribly ignorant and intolerant no
we're not gonna back this up with ya
baby
this is a proactive place talking about
we got golden girls here if you're
serious I am gonna take at least one of
these and start watching golden girl
that's a little she is part of the crew
she's the ad yep thank you thank you I'm
so much you're a wonderful ad Olivia
look at that the journey begins in
Brendan V I'm gonna think of you every
single episode I'm gonna figure out
which of these lovely I think I'm a
Blanche but I don't know what that means
so you know we'll find out my favorites
gay porn I once saw hmm was there's you
know what is way too graphic to get into
but there was yeah I just feel like I'm
hanging out with two homeless guys may I
request a special birthday present from
y'all my birthday is on April 30th would
y'all do a live stream that day if y'all
can't I understand booing amazing you
know what Aneesa you know what what date
is that fall I'm checking because I'm
gonna say yes that's a Thursday
let's try Thursday let's try Thursday
it'll be like in college college
Thursday was party let's try Thursday
out let's see how it goes and yeah we
will do it mark on the calendar mark it
on the calendar John if I forget I'm
blaming you
plain and simple it's nuts completely
Wayne and simple John you should blame
it already chars e in the chat is saying
Fresh Prince of bel-air that's another
feel-good show right roots that's a good
call I used to sneak Fresh Prince on my
TV see I had a TV when I was a kid that
had a combination VCR and an antenna on
the top so I couldn't get much TV but I
could get a couple basic channels and I
would hold up lock the door and watch
fresh Brown oh Michael where your fate
your channels might feel good show your
comment is my feel-good show what is my
favorite you Callan Jackson is asking
John what is your favorite Yuki
why is your favorite youkai TV show UK
show how John Campea did like a
seven our live stream is VR yeah as I do
I love being here we're not on that
right now I love being here but he'd
stay sharp for like hours and I'm like
we're hanging out we're loose now oh man
are we if we're talking at the seat
are we talking recent UK or classic UK
because recently I just re-watched
Fawlty Towers and Fawlty Towers is
delightful classic John Cleese post
Monty Python comedy Little Britain I
like a lot obviously we'd be watching
Doctor Who Doctor Who's great I'm trying
to think there's gonna be some great
like British deep cut that I'm gonna
pull out at some point and be like you
know black but I haven't actually seen
black books Black Adder is pretty good
we'll just I'll just keep this going
until you find something else to talk
also sweet sweet baby daddy is show it
is show so I'm not your baby
well you could be it's also a movie I
mean baby daddy means a lot of things
chase gardener thank you so much buddy
feel good show community that is a great
show community good [ __ ]
dude thank you chase Carter I mean he's
great community and watch tiny Glover
yeah he's terrific on that show and and
in lethal weapon what's your joke yeah
you know Mel Gibson's on community which
have you seen when we live together Java
washing mmunity a lot of us go to shows
yeah like community and quite a bit in
fact I just reached the quarantine
episode which holds up quite well
flightless dust oh dude great avatar if
you guys haven't seen onward make sure
to watch onward yeah thoughts on st4
think they'll make another it
what's st for stranger things is what my
guess was cuz they don't call those they
just call seasons three four
you know you young kids just can't smash
it any more than you know brie vh gosh
but thank you for the supership in the
same breath oh you're really terrific
well it's you kids and your smarts to
your in response to your thing because
you're saying that we got Kiki Gardner
mmm who is saying okay I lost it I'm
sorry
oh yeah someone help Mandy's oh space
okay
stranger things for well I think
stranger things for everything we've
learned so far of like hopper being back
is a hundred percent expected I was
never fully sold on it even though I was
sad I was of course it's like I thought
was cool they led with that I'm sorry
it's sad that it's like it's it's sad
that it's been postponed because I was
excited it was like whoa this is coming
wait earlier than the other ones they
got postponed I think they'll make
another it I hope they don't I hope they
really hope they don't know I don't
think there would be a reason to know
unless you reboot it again in ten years
and make it all on movie or something
I was weirdly going to sleep a couple
nights ago and I randomly thought of the
opening to it chapter two if you guys
haven't seen that they guys and and was
it go Dairy Dairy yeah bunch homophobic
[ __ ] beat up these two this gay
couple like beat the [ __ ] out of them
and then Pennywise like eats 100 or
something right yeah yeah that happens
it is so such like a a brutal opening
visceral and in a very pointed opening
and everyone was talking about like
because I was working on a story I was
think about like good big opening and
then just finally pop it in my head and
they and and then I was and then I was
thinking about like what the [ __ ] was a
point of leading with that opening other
than the fact that that scene is in the
book like apparently that's in the book
that scene yeah that's what I heard yeah
leads into like penny western back for
like why specifically hardcore
homophobia beating up gang
what was the point of that yeah it
doesn't seem like the movie if you're
gonna do that you should do something
more with it I think that ties it in
better or has some point to it and you
would have to do something with penny
wise with it in general that has some
kind of allegorical value that relates
to tolerance right yeah it just feels
like yeah like something that says a
little bit about what dairies like at
the moment and here's a horrific
set-piece and we're gonna forget all
about you know and yeah it's a bit on I
I don't want them to see people agreeing
that onward needs more love thank you
guys yeah that's a good one music now
it's a my feel-good movie my husband
Vinny yes I love them that's one of my
favorite movies that's one this one Joe
Pesci's like you're talking to me you're
talking to me I'm the only one here
y'all good you huh yo just when I think
I'm out they pull me back in so many
classics a classic man and spider-man's
mom so it's a 19-9 thank you buddy
mrs. Doubtfire drive-by fruiting all my
love popping good pics drive-by fruiting
I've never heard of that but mrs.
Doubtfire is classic mrs. Doubtfire is a
horror movie waiting to be rebooted you
see you see that viral trailer right oh
of course I shout out to my girl Mara I
definitely owe you foo now don't worry I
thought about that an hour ago it's okay
hardcore Henry we were featured on like
our trailer here we were featured action
of this hoster it was the only time and
feature in any movie we've been we were
featured in a couple of their things and
I to this day I am going to track down
there was a graphic novel they pulled a
bigger quote for and put on from us so I
got I got some love for her core it was
really good that was very really well
this is this is this is the iceberg and
I hear in terms Johnny's gonna be late
to his pizza Medoro Thank You Brendan B
yeah dude Johnny huh follow him
especially if always you proved you're
not gay
Brenden listen can you confirm to
Everett you would know allegedly yeah
I'm following you right now buddy
I'm following you right now buddy uh
shouts out submit it guys I just want to
shout out come brother the way what
Eminem has with Elton John that's what
John has a Brendan V now yes yes he's
gonna be my goat
I'm follow Brendan V Brendan V peace
love and flaming hot cheetos I'm
following you back my friend may you no
no mmm oh dude
okay some other great British shows by
the way spaced is a great British show
I've seen some of peaky blinders which
we've got a lot of requests for on
patreon
and also broadchurch fantastic British
show and uh am i liked sorry whenever
anybody asks I just want to get good
good page on when you're talking I'm not
look I'm thinking about what I'm going
on all right Aneesa
I love Olivia if you guys don't know
Olivia is my beautiful and supportive
funny sexy girlfriend I mean saying
Ophelia all this time I want to watch
Breakfast at Tiffany's with her and seen
the rain yeah if you have any criticism
sorts Breakfast at Tiffany's in front of
her including the whole you know Asian
thing that goes on in that movie no see
that was I write that was like well
Robert Downey jr. satire guys all right
Mickey Rooney is the biggest Asian right
she knows already the problems but
she'll kick you out of the room just
saying but thank you and he's saying yes
well live stream on that day you've been
unbelievable good most fervent suppose
taking care of the channel Oh
yeah thank you absolutely absolutely and
Jared pen I mean yes like I'm answering
all your questions at once but thank you
so much for all the major contributions
you've been doing
Jared pen Impractical Jokers Parks and
Rec home improvement home improvement
tool time
Wilson had social distancing down that's
what we should all be studying right now
you guys haven't seen home improvement
Wilson was the neighbor yep whose face
you never saw yes always that was the
thing as a half right here was always
covered and then even when he come out
so when they do some of that like sitcom
like greet in the cast he'd always cover
his face
you never saw his face never saw it I'm
surprised I have no idea I had social
distancing down I'm surprised there are
memes of that yet like just taking the
web by Store I feel like now is the time
I wanted to do a meme of [ __ ] John
David Washington from Tennant and put
and put a [ __ ] disposable mask on the
face just be like this guy knew what was
coming
John David Washington is my feel-good
movie what I'll say to this one is not
not surprising Michael where says before
Henry is the best first-person action
movie that I have ever seen look at
Eliza
well John will be your token gay it's
any time my friends thanks buddy
Z oh I have one all right guys we've
made it to the end that's it that's all
she wrote you're the last one Anissa
thank you so much for being you thank
you to everyone who has been here in the
stream the whole time seriously every
one of these has provided a different
one this is easily our most unfocused
live stream usually a different day it's
easily the most weird it's been a
[ __ ] weird
as day we're asked couple days and
honestly I got to tell you guys I know I
started off in the big give your ear in
the beginning I started off with talking
about like some bad and some terrible
news and yeah interacting with you guys
has made me um feel better yes it made
me feel a lot better and I just came
here to [ __ ] around for the last two
hours thank you this is yeah the thanks
to you guys so seriously I really mean
it not to pull a weird like I'm not
trying to be goofy with the reference
but especially with these live streams
it feels like there's sort of a
symbiotic quality where it's like we all
bounce back and forth and it's like the
most fun like we do a lot of fun stuff
for work but this is like the most fun
this is yeah actually this is actually
the like when we're editing it's not
really like we're doing it and we're
like we make it fun like the video fun
but it's usually kind of stressful
because you're like you gotta get done
at a certain point to get some bonus or
time yeah so thank you and we don't
forget the bandanas and sincerely chase
garner appreciate in this addition super
each ever and now Brendon you can harass
me all week chilled you good call
daredevil another good call right there
Thank You chase you want me thick and
Anissa I'd say right now you have earned
that numero uno most certainly number
one now matrix stay safe guys love all
love everyone who's been here the entire
review just like checked in will do one
next week at some point a rule of thumb
is like you know we don't we don't want
to make the channel only live streams
like we love doing them but you know we
like doing like doing videos where were
you know shooting it seemed like that
yeah yeah it seems like this worked out
a way where it's like once a week to
unwind this seems like the perfect thing
to do exactly it couldn't I don't think
that this would be the life's blood of
the channel but yeah as a weekly
engagement I think this is turned out
into something nice for someone who's
been shedding a lot of Tears as past
couple days this has been easily the
most positive thing I know this is all
week and then this last few days I think
like seriously thank you I'm gonna go
spend some time with my girlfriend right
now
I love everyone here thank you and I'll
also say this that sounds like a good
idea see you guys